For VR, I had experiences with two labs
I wanted to do this kind of hard super-realistic
experience which was the
military experience where they really
try to simulate what it's like to be in combat.
So in the travel lab I saw we just
wore goggles. But if you went into their real lab
they would they would pump in smells
they would vibrate the floor to
emulate kind of driving motor shaking
explosions and stuff like that. And then
I went to this lab at Stanford called the
Virtual Human Interaction Lab which is
like the magic realism side of the VR
world and they're really inspired by
Jaron Lanier and kind of this idea of
alternate bodies. So one of the things that
I did in there--they never told me
what I was going to do they just said to
the lab. And I got there one day and they
said get down on all fours and wear
these infrared markers. They put them on
my back and they put them on my arm.
OK fine. And they snapped on the VR and
I was a cow. Right? And I was like... okay.
What they're experimenting with is that
Jaron Lanier kind of famously asked this
question of why do you have to have a
human body in virtual reality?
He said imagine that you're a lobster
ok you drive arm one with this arm
drive two with this arm. How do you
drive the rest of the arms? So the
question is how well can you adapt
to these novel bodies. They put me in a cow
and I could see my cow doppelganger
across from me because it's actually
very hard to wear a helmet and crawl
around on the floor and look at your own
body at the cow body. So they did
all of these things that kind of bonded
me to the cow. Do this
and then cow would do that. And then they
said okay here's your job you have to
gain all of this weight so you reach a
certain number of pounds.
So I go over and I eat. I go over
and I drink. And then they say go back to
your starting point because now we're
going to send you to the slaughterhouse.
Right? And then the floor starts to shake
and this truck like it starts making that
beep beep beep back up noises and I
freaked out. I can hear myself I
have a tape of myself and in it I'm
yelling "This is brutal" like at
no one in particular
and VR is like being on stage
you're not supposed to break the
illusion you know of the fourth wall. I am
really scared. And it's because basically
I have come to empathize with
this other that quickly. Like I
feel so responsible for this other
imaginary being and that turns out to be
what they were trying to test. In the
real experiment what they would have
done afterwards is kind of put me
through all of these batteries of tests
to gauge how I felt about animals and
how likely i was to donate to animal
rights causes. And that was like
a real experience. It was very visceral.
And the other things that they did after
that was that they made me a coral because
they wanted to see how people would
behave in a body that is even more like
yourself. And then
they did a thing where they gave
me a third arm. And the idea was how
quickly would I learn how to drive a
third arm. And I'll tell you it happened like that.
[inaudible question...] Ok so... in VR
the third arm is coming out of my chest
and I'm wearing controllers on my wrist.
They didn't tell me how to drive it.
They just said make your third arm move.
They said tap that thing. It was just like that.
It was an amazing experience.
Yeah. Did I answer all the...?
("What's next for virtual reality?")
Both of these labs were trying to do things
for basically for pro-social reasons to help
people. To either prevent a
disorder cure disorder or kind of make
people more empathetic with their
environment and with other people.
I thought that was a really like awesome
application of VR. They were
talking about using it with students.
Could you bring students in
and instead of reading about global warming
and the effect on ocean life would you
be able to empathize with ocean life?
I thought that was a cool idea.
The big question for me is how long
does that effect last, right? So I would love
to see more research that shows how long
what happens in VR lingers in your real life.